la conviction que j'ai c'est que au
terme de ce mouvement de déçus et glace
qu'on a vécu sur très longue période
parce que les nationalisations commence
dès 1908 ya une première très grandes
nationalisations
on a connu des vagues alternative de
nationalisation et de privatisations et
j'ai le sentiment qu'au bout de plus
d'un siècle de ce mouvement il ya de la
part des citoyens une frustration c'est
que le sentiment dominant c'est que la
propriété publique souvent c'est aussi
mal comporté que la propriété privée
je rejoindrai peut-être mon
contradicteur sur ce point l'état
actionnaire gérer le capitalisme d'état
dans un univers qui est très
financiarisé se comporte aussi mal
prenons juste un exemple à titre
d'illustration renault dont
l'actionnaire principal reste encore
l'état avait 15 % c'est dans cet univers
totalement financiarisé ce gros porc
très mal avec un patron par exemple
l'ancien carlos ghosn qui avait 15
millions d'euros de rémunération avec
celles de nissan
et puis des inégalités en bas de
l'échelle sociale penser que chez
renault
un ouvrier sur deux est en intérim donc
c'est l'endroit où on a été le plus loin
dans le système à l'anglo-saxonne des
working poors des travailleurs pauvres
avec des inégalités formidable et donc
je pense qu'on a vécu très longtemps sur
une fausse alternative d'un côté l'état
de l'autre le marché
1 la gauche notamment a vécu sur cette
idée et je trouve que au point nous en
sommes il faut tirer un bilan des deux
les privatisations c'est un saccage au
prive les citoyens de bien qui sont les
leurs est on en train de saper l'état
social et puis mes par ailleurs le les
nationalisations pour la plupart été un
fiasco on pourra donner beaucoup
d'autres exemples pitoyable triste
l'histoire de pechiney qui se termine
par une op en voilà et donc je pense que
le débat maintenant le débat pour
l'avenir
c'est à sortir de cette fausse
alternative
[Musique]